My husband's about to go on a 25 hour road trip,
so I decided to make him some bubblegum lollipops
as a little treat on his drive.
Started out by making my bubblegum
by spreading some powdered sugar on some wax paper,
melting down my gum base,
transferring that into the middle of my mounts I created.
I added some apple flavor to one of them
and added some vanilla extract to the other
to make two different kinds of flavors
before kneading in my powdered sugar.
Once a good portion of them was absorbed,
I cut them up and formed them into little gumballs
before putting them aside while I got started on making my lollipops.
Obviously had to try one and make sure that it was the right
consistency, which it was.
Then moved on to making my lollipops
by combining some sugar and syrup in a pot
before placing that on my stove to boil.
In the meantime,
I put my gumballs on top of my lollipop sticks
before checking on my sugar mixture on the stove.
Wanted to keep a close eye on it to make sure it reached the right
temperature for adding in some more apple syrup
and green food colouring
since I was making apple flavoured lollipops.
Once it reached the hard crack stage,
I transferred it over to my silicone molds
before placing my lollipop sticks inside.
Speed up the cooling process.
I placed them in the fridge
and then had lucky Get them out of the molds,
because I couldn't,
for some reason.
Got them out and couldn't contain his excitement.
So he tried one of them and absolutely love them.
Wrapped up the other one so he could take them on his road trip.